Let me illustrate this again. For any sample, you know how to compute a confidence interval.
If the null hypothesis is inside the confidence interval of the observed sample,
everything is okay and you believe null hypothesis.
Conversely, if the null hypothesis falls outside, you don't believe null hypothesis
and you accept the alternate hypothesis.
So simple is the hypothesis testing and you use confidence intervals instead of,
for example, the binomial distribution and that's really the common case.
Let me just briefly summarize what we're doing.
Given the sample of data, you compute the mean, you compute the variance,
you get the t-value at some desired error probability p
and you have to make sure you pick the correct one if it's one-sided,
and pick a different one for the two-sided.
Then the plus/minus term in the confidence interval is simply this number over here
times the square root of the empirical variance for N.
Then I would have to be really cryptic but I've just given it to you,
but by now, it should make a lot of sense and because we practiced every element of it.
The mean, the empirical variance, getting a number from a table,
and then compute the size of the confidence interval which we then put into the plus/minus terms.
So µ minus this is the lower bound µ plus is the upper bound of the confidence interval
according to the confidence level specified for the error probability p.
Let's put this into action--a dance club operator advertised the fact
that the average age of its client is 26.
You walk in and encounter the following people--four people are 21,
six people are 24, seven people are 26, 11 people are 29,
and two people are actually 40 years old for a total of N=30.
Now, compute for mean whether you know to trust the statement that the average was 26.
And let's do so. Obviously, the fact that there is two 40-year-olds is a little bit disturbing.
Let's do so in stages and I want to guide you through this. First, let's calculate the mean.